ich habe die beste Business Class der
Welt getestet und so viel habe ich
bezahlt nachdem ich drei Wochen in
Thailand war habe ich mich dazu
entschieden den Rückflug Business Class
zu fliegen braucht das erste Mal
Langstrecke Business Class in meinem
Leben und letztendlichen internetratings
geht der Platz eins der besten Business
Class der Welt an Katar Airways
angekommen Bangkok am Flughafen ging es
erstmal in die Lounge die war schon
super krass Garten richtig großes Buffet
und ich kann auch alle Karten bestellen
und dann stand die erste tappe an im
Airbus A380 ging es von Bangkok nach
Doha war schon super nice genug Platz
super leckeres Essen aber das Highlight
kam noch kurz als Info die Business
Class bei Katar airway sieht nicht immer
gleich aus es kommt auf den Flugzeugtyp
an mit dem unterwegs seid von dort nach
Frankfurt bin ich dann allerdings in
einer Boeing 777 und der damit
verbundenen sweet gelandet die coolsten
ist das beste was es gibt du hast
absoluten eigenen Bereich kannst dich
richtig entspannt hinlegen super modern
natürlich wieder alles mögliche Essen in
Hammer Frühstück ich bin wirklich noch
nie so entspannt gereist und so
entspannt angekommen und gekostet hat
mich das ganze 1000 700 € ohne Meilen
einfach bezahlt